this was a fantastic game overtime
Clippers Lakers big turnover it was
great Hands by Austin Reed and he
finishes off with a nice L to the king
go get it LeBron James 35 points 12
rebounds seven assists in this game all
the stars showing out Austin Reed didn't
have the greatest game had a nice
overtime though finished with 15 points
Lakers up by four at that point
back come the Clippers and it's kawhai
Leonard tough that's with a hand in your
face Anthony Davis Kawai playing 41
minutes in this game hug yeah 38
points three-point game right
here and this is going to ice it
Christian
Wood that was
huge comes down from the weak side had
10 points in the he's a nice offensive
boost for him right he does he's always
been able to
score with that the Lakers what a game
got a game early in the season a little
playoff
Feld 130 1225 but just look at all the
numbers from the Star players Paul
George fouling out of this game but at
35 points some big buckets down the
stretch Russell Westbrook a good one the
LeBron James 35 points 12 rebounds seven
assists let's hear from him
this thing was a heavyweight fight you
guys are able to pull it out and erase
an 11 game win streak they had against
you how did you do
it we got stops um except from the first
quarter we started to Bunker down
defensively PG Kawai Russ those guys
were spectacular tonight and we just
want to get timely stops make timely
shots and uh we was able to get back
into the game and uh I mean win a game I
mean we know it's a dog fight every time
H these guys and uh tonight we was
finally able to get one off of them you
mentioned getting back in the game the
team went 19 versus 7 while you were on
the bench but you were engaged when they
were on the defensive end what were you
telling them from the bench I mean it's
all about just trying to get stops be
aggressive great shooting team right
there so as much as you can just trying
to make him a little bit uncomfortable
or as comfortable as you can cuz they
can shoot the ball extremely well and uh
we started to get up you know to the air
space a little bit more force a little
bit more contested shots and then was
able to clean glass lastly and I feel
like we'll have this conversation
numerous times over the rest of your
career but you scored 35 tonight the
most for a player in his 21st year or
beyond what does that mean to you at
this stage of your career um it resulted
in the win that's the only thing that
matters to me um I work on my body every
day I work on my mind every day to be
able to be available to my teammates and
uh this was three and four nights for us
and we were short body no Ry um late
scratch voran uh uh Prince uh no gay
Vincent we' been without Vando for the
season so far uh and everybody had to
step up in absence so um you know big
win for us and I'm happy I was able to
contribute a little
bit as a basketball fan that was just
awesome yes I mean that was awesome even
getting that overtime but just seeing
the Stars play play Heavy minutes uh and
produce the way they did you know I
think 3D um we got a chance to see Kawai
Leonard and Paul George play at a high
level with Russell Westbrook and we know
we want to see kawhai and Paul George
because of the injuries they got a
chance to play then we got CH see this
guy it's amazing I think sometimes we
just take it for granted what he's doing
in his 21st season for 19 12 rebound
seven assist that's for a 22y old that's
playing as as hard as he can play I mean
his jumping ability his commitment to
winning he still looks like
he's eager to win basketball games and
this is what the game five so I I think
it was a treat for us to get a chance to
watch that one three agree with you so
we talk about story lines I have to look
at the Clipper side and say how how does
Ty L now with another addition of a
weapon that can do so many different
things where you're three guys with 24
35 and 38 now you're saying wait a minut
I'm adding James Harden to this now so
so the offense is not going to be a
problem but down the stretch I think tyo
is gonna figure out when LeBron James is
playing the way he's playing ad's
playing the way he's playing and then
you got a guy like Christian Wood comes
off the bench and gets 10 I want to give
Cam reddish some a little bit of love
his eight points was needed tonight
Smitty he's one of those guys that we
looked at earlier in his career this
might be his last stop so when you watch
this game tonight you're like man each
coach was playing chess not Checkers
down the stretch but when you got a guy
like LeBron James you got the ball out
of his hands he made the right pass but
you didn't have a backside rebounder
that's why Christian Wood gets that
follow-up dunk to kind of ice the game
now I'm kind of Sor that James hard
didn't play tonight you know what I mean
like I understand why he didn't play
gives a one more time but imagine James
Harden in that situation in his first
game with the Clippers it makes it very
interesting that that that's like
playing NBA 2K in front of you got all
these players on both teams and it's in
La uh next time for James hard next time
but it was a treat to watch the guys who
played because it does feel like over
the last what four years we've kind of
been robbed of this match up just cuz of
Health right ital to watch this games
to watch this game tonight a lot of fun